this is a production of Cornell
University thank you so much Gary for
that very nice introduction and thank
you to all of you for attending my talk
today I'm really excited to share a
little bit about my research experience
and and thoughts I have going uh forward
as a vegetable breeder at at Cornell uh
so I tried to tailor the talk more
uh for the pathology audience but I'd
like to start just by giving an overview
of my current research program um so I'm
a tomato and eggplant breeder here at
Cornell uh there are three kind of
overarching objectives of my lab's
research those are to gen discover the
genetic basis of traits of importance
either to Growers or consumers to model
strategies for for how to implement new
technologies in the context of a very
applied cultivar development program and
then finally to develop and release
varieties of tomato and eggplant that
meet the needs of stakeholders in New
York and the Northeastern United States
so I'll talk I'll talk a little bit more
about each of those objectives and keep
trying to Adventure slides with
this so in terms of cultivar development
uh for New York in the Northeast uh they
are really diverse stakeholders markets
and needs in our region so talking about
tomato tomato is grown in open field
it's grown in high tunnels uh also in
our state we have companies growing
tomatoes and some of the most most
Hightech environments that tomatoes are
grown in around the world this is green
Empire Farms outside of Syracuse where
they grow tomatoes under 64 Acres of
glass tomatoes are grown for wholesale
markets uh including at produce auctions
which is an imported uh outlet for many
of the Amish medanite growers in our
region they're grown and sold directly
to Consumers at farmers markets and farm
stands and through csas New York is also
a state where over 90% of the population
lives in urban environments there are a
lot of people interested uh in growing
vegetables in these environments and
there are a lot of needs to develop
varieties that that do well in those in
those distinct
environments uh finally New York is a
very diverse State um and there are many
people uh uh in our state who are
interested in growing crops that are
important to their Heritage and eggplant
is a really great uh species uh to meet
some of those needs U because there's so
many diverse types that people are are
used to from around the world one of
those types is the African EG or sanum
aop pum seen here that my life is
starting some research on as
well so I mentioned I'm interested in
testing how to implement new
technologies in an applied vegetable
cultivar development program and uh one
of the things that I'm really interested
in is genomic selection and if if you're
familiar with that genomic selection is
the idea of
uh of combining genotypic and phenotypic
information
on what's called a training population
using that information to develop
statistical models and then applying
those models to populations of plants
for which we might not have any
phenotype information we might not ever
observed their phenotypes we can
actually predict their phenotypes based
exclusively on markers this is a
technology that's been implemented in uh
pretty widely in breeding programs for
agronomic crops over the past 10 years
or so but the adoption in vegetables has
been a little bit slower for for many
reasons um you know one I think traits
and vegetables are more difficult to
quantify um either because of the
throughput right we can't drive a
combine through a field and quantify
yield on thousands of plots we have to
go out there and pick them multiple
times through the season and also some
traits are just more intangible and
difficult to turn into numbers so you
know really successful breeders can walk
through their field and Visually
identify plants that are superior in
terms of their growth habit their fruit
shape their color those are things that
are more challenging to quickly turn it
into numbers but uh I'm really
interested in working with uh the
expertise we have here on campus to kind
of showcase how we can uh Implement
these Technologies in in a practical
way uh finally uh genetic Discovery and
pre-breeding this this has been one of
the most important legacies of public
sector vegetable breeders um in tomato
you know if you go to the farmers market
and look at Tomatoes you'll see such a
iety of shapes and colors and sizes but
despite all that morphological diversity
there's actually pretty limited genetic
diversity especially compared to what's
found in uh the related species of
domesticated tomato in uh uh in in wild
species abmic to South America uh plant
breeders have introgressed you know so
many genes of commercial importance from
these wild species into domesticated
tomato that if you look at commercially
available varieties coming out now and
compare them it's commercially available
varieties coming out 50 or 75 years ago
the genetic diversity is much greater
because of how much wild species DNA has
been introgressed into
tomato um one of the projects that my
lab is starting to work on is working
with sanum cities which is actually one
of the most distantly related Allied
species of tomato it grows in the AMA
desert of Chile which is a region uh uh
that receives on average like half an
inch of rainfall a year uh it's it's
pretty remarkable if you look at these
pictures these are Landscapes that are
like devoid of all plant life but
somehow miraculously there are like wild
tomatoes growing there uh for for many
years this was a species that breeders
didn't really have access to working
with because of cross compatibility
barriers uh but recently a team at UC
Davis uh through a very complex Crossing
scheme and many years of effort were
able to develop a set of integration
lines
DNA from this species in the background
of domesticates made we're starting to
look at that for some abiotic stress
tolerances but you know the most
important traits that have come from uh
wild tomatoes have been disease
resistances and you know in the rest of
my talk I'm going to talk about how it's
important to understand the genetics not
just of the host but of the pathogen as
well uh you know this this is obviously
not a novel concept at all it's pretty
fundamental I think to the field of
plant mythology was demonstrated by Flor
in the in the 50s working on Flax and
flax rest who showed that the disease
outcome depended on the genotype of the
plant and also the genotype of the
pathogen which he summarized you know
very succinctly in his conclusion to
this very seminal paper uh but in terms
of how I kind of like came around to
this concept you know 70 years after
everybody else did
uh I I want to talk about the research I
did on phyto or capsy as a graduate
student um if you're unfamiliar with
phyto capsy it causes a disease called
phyto blight this is a disease that's
very difficult to manage um you know for
for Growers for a couple of reasons it
produces these thick wall breasting
spores these are sexual spores that can
survive in the soil for over 10 years uh
dormant in the absence of a susceptible
it also has a really explosive asexual
life cycle so the spanga that you can
see on the surface of this pumpkin fruit
here uh in wet conditions they
differentiate into 20 to 40 mold zores
that in wet conditions can swim through
water and identify new hosts to effect
so FAL blood causes a range of disease
symptoms different disease syndromes it
causes damping off it causes root and
Crown rot causes fruit rot it affects
solci species curbit a couple of other
important vegetable species and one kind
of consistent thing that we've seen with
Pho light is that often it's introduced
to farms in flood waters um so a farmer
may have no experience with this disease
there'll be a really severe uh rainfall
event a neighboring you know body of
water will flood and then a week or two
later they'll see you know really uh
severe uh crop loss in their fields once
it's introduced it's pretty much
impossible to eradicate and un with you
know change that we see in our weather
weather patterns it seems like it's
becoming more and more
commmon so when I started my PhD I I
came into an ongoing project on breeding
for resistance to squash at at that time
and and actually still today there's
really no commercial available
resistance in squash to phyo root and
Crown Rod this was a project that was a
collaboration between Chris's lab and
and Michael mich's uh vegetable breeding
program the methods that that we used
for uh selecting resistance were pretty
straightforward but but very effective
we would grow our populations of
seedlings in the greenhouse inoculate
them with the suspension of zoospores
and then a week or two later you know
sort through all those dying plants and
find the ones that are the most green
and pop those up and use those for more
Crossing uh and and like I said this
this worked pretty well uh we put the
results of this project into field
trials uh here you can see a susceptible
toini C
uh or maybe you can't see it because the
plants are pretty much dead at this
point a couple weeks after
inoculation uh this is actually the
source of resistance that was used in
this resistance breeding program you can
see it has somewhat of an intermediate F
Type and then the lines that we
developed uh actually had resistance
level superior to the resistant parent
uh unfortunately in the process of
selecting you know more or less
exclusively based on seedling resistance
we lost a lot of the traits that make it
good as a zucchini but uh we did show
that you can select for resistance to
phot I spent a lot of time in the
greenhouse inoculating seedlings and
associating variation in uh the disease
response with variation uh in their DNA
polymorphisms and identifying qtl
related to resistance uh within several
different experiments we mapped the
total of six qtl related to phyo Crown
and root route
resistance we found that these qtl
individually uh had very small effect uh
if you look at these plots these are
showing theic effects of markers in
these regions U and if you look at their
effect on relative adbc it's very slight
and individually these markers explain
anywhere from like two to 10% of the
fenic
variation um however collectively uh you
know they can make pretty big
differences so uh you know when you
increase the number of qtl that are
fixed for the resistant o uh lines that
had five of these resistant uh
resistance Qs compared to lines that had
zero had pretty substantial difference
in terms of their disease
response that being said you know this
is pretty challenging for a breeder to
work with um because you know uh a
breeder is not just selecting for these
five genes there's probably many more
genes that we weren't able to map there
even of smaller effect they're selecting
for uh resistance to other diseases
growth habit fruit shape shelf life uh
even When selecting for like a single
qualitative R Gene often it's difficult
because of the other genes that tend to
come along with it so selecting for five
small effect genes uh really
challenging one one thing that wasn't
challenging about phyo root and Crown
rot resistance and squash was that it
was really consisting across different
strains of the pathogen uh so here you
can see disease incidence over time with
in two varieties um our resistant
breeding line and susceptible as a candy
check the different line types are
different strains of the pathogen we did
this a few times with different strains
both from around New York and around the
country and we found pretty similar
results consistently it didn't really
matter uh what strain was we inoculated
with uh they all caused similar levels
of disease and there were no
interactions the resistance level of the
plant genotype was not conditional which
I it was challenged
with so that that's a very different
case than the case in Pepper and I'm
going to talk uh more about that in
depth um the way that I became exposed
to um you know this phenomenon in Pepper
was through field trials at the Cornell
phyo form so many of you probably know
that in Geneva uh there are fields that
are dedicated exclusively to research on
phyo BL uh you know Chris
lab uses those uh for many research
projects and it's also a resource for
breeders around the country uh to
conduct trials to see how their germ
plasm um performs uh in inoculated
trials so so being Chris's student who
worked on phyo capsy I also had the uh
honor of managing some of these trials
which was uh a really excellent learning
experience
uh but it was also something that we you
know there were challenges as well uh if
you look at this picture you can see my
labmate at the time Ally she's she's
dumping hyto infested vermiculite into
every single hole that we're going to
transplant our pepper seedlings into I
would then go back through like two or
three times over the next several weeks
and spray each plant with a suspension
of Zo spores but still Often by the end
of the season we would have fields that
look like this um breeders would want to
come out and select their most resistant
plants but everything would look really
healthy uh wasn't always easy to get
disease we started to suspect that it
maybe because of the isolate that we
were using so this is like a typical
result that we would see with um the
isolate that we had been using uh we've
killed maybe a thousand out of 2 200
plants which I guess I guess isn't bad
but still some of the Breeders we worked
with were frustrated they wanted to see
more differences and select more plants
especially in their early generation
material so the uh in 2018 we decided to
use a different isolate I'll talk more
about how we found that isolate um but
here we actually like had the opposite
problem uh by the end of the season only
150 of the 2,800 plants we put in that
field had survived uh this was honestly
probably worse than the result we had
the first case the Breeders weren't able
to select any plants because all the
plants were were
dead so how did we discover that isolate
that we inoculated that field with uh in
the winter between uh field seasons in
2017 and 2018 I went to the lab and
grabbed just 30 cultures you know
somewhat randomly from uh Chris's uh
culture collection and alculated them
onto three different bell pepper hybrids
with different kind of overall levels of
resistance and I was really Amazed by
how much variation that we saw in terms
of the disease caused by these isolates
uh ranging from you know strains that
were only a ble to kill you know a small
number of most susceptible variety so
strains that caused high levels of
disease in all three of the varieties
including Paladin which is uh marketed
in Su catalog so it's resistant to
phy if you see here um where is it let's
see 0664 D1 so this is the strain we had
been using in the field
trials we went all the way to the right
side of the plot to 1455 for the next
year's trial you you know in hindsight
we probably should have gone somewhere
in the middle and not uh all the way to
the Other
Extreme but you know this was a a really
uh interesting I guess Revelation for me
you know the reason that I got into
plant breeding was because I was so
fascinated by fpic diversity in crop
plants and vegetables especially and to
realize that there's all this fent typic
diversity in microbes as well uh you
know just really really struck me and I
I started to become more interested like
less in the different between the
planets and more kind of the differences
between the strains right like I wanted
to know what what was it about this
strain that enabled it to cause disease
on Paladin and
MRA uh unable to do
that so I was really lucky to have
access to uh lots of excellent resources
in Chris's lab so you know we had a a
culture collection with hundreds of
isolate soy
capsy there had been pre previous grad
students who had worked on this pathogen
and worked out like a lot of uh the
details that were needed to do this
experiments so Chris's student Amara dun
developed like really excellent
protocols for culturing and using
inoculum and doing inoculations with
this pathogen uh we also had experience
with highdensity Gene typing F capsy A
lot of those bioinformatic pipelines
were developed by Chris's student uh
Marin Carlson so I was able to kind of
put these things together and think
about how to answer some of research
questions I had and I thought you know
could we genotype maybe the culture
collection with high density snit
markers inoculate it onto a series of
different pepper varieties and then
identify markers associated with
variation and virulence on these
different pepper
varieties so so that's that's what we
did uh the first thing we had to do was
assemble our culture collection ction uh
many of these cultures you know we
already had um in store they had been
collected at some point over previous 10
years or so Chris also had really
excellent relationships with Growers and
extension Specialists were able to go
and collect more
strains uh it was actually kind of like
a almost like a like a treasury hunt
like I remember going to Wegman's and
finding a ring zucchini and bringing it
to the lab and and being like amazed to
pull F caps see out of uh so it was fun
to kind of expand this this culture
collection this plot you can see the
sites that the strains came from each
circle is like a different field and the
size of the circle is proportional to
how many strains we collected out of
that field we also got a small number of
strains from other states as
well so we genotyped the strains with
Gen typing by sequencing which is uh A
reduced representation whole genum
sequencing approach it's a way to
basically assay Snips at thousands of
sites uh across the
genome um one thing that we could do
with this data was we looked at the
pairwise genetic similarity between all
of our isolates and when you do that and
you make a histogram of all those
pairwise genetic similarities you get
this uh Tri modal distribution and what
what that is is that this peak here of
pairs of isolates that are least related
to each other these are isolates from
different field sites the peak in the
middle these are isolates that are um
genetically distinct but from the same
field site so related to each other and
then we have this peak all the way at
the right close to 100% genetic
similarity that includes technical
replicates of the same isolate sequence
multiple times which also told us that
pairs of isolates that appear here are
likely clonally derived from the same
common ancestor so we could use this to
identify different clonal groups of itop
capsy in our isolate uh
collection one thing that we found which
made sense with the biology of the path
was that every phonal group was unique
to a particular field and your uh you
know which uh is what we expected given
that the asexual scores are very
shortlived whereas the sexual scores
product of meiosis are the ones that
over winter from year to
year so you know just looking at one
isolate per clonal group and looking at
the population structure of this
collection of isolates here if you look
at the principal components analysis
plot on the left and the neighbor
joining Tree on the right the different
colors represent different regions of
New York and the different symbols
within a color are different field sites
um and what we found was that in almost
every case uh an isolate from a
particular field site was more likely to
be closely related to another isolate
from that same field site than to
another isolate in our collection and
this was even true at really uh small
spatial scales so if you look at these
per triangles here and these purple
circles here these came from two fields
in Western New York that were separated
by about a mile uh you can see that
they're more closely related to each
other than they are to any of the other
isolet that we sequenced but they're
still totally differentiated from one
another so it's just this really
interesting
um you know uh example of how these like
pretty rare founder events of how these
these populations are introduced to
Fields uh end up contributing to pretty
strong genetic differentiation over time
through drift or
selection another thing that we found
was evidence of it seemed like you know
a pretty widespread chromosomal copy
number
variation uh the way we could look at
this was by looking at uh read depths uh
sequencing read depths and in particular
read depths for heterozygous sites so if
if you sequence a heterozygous site on
average you should expect about half of
the reads that you sequence to belong to
one Al and the other half to belong to
the other Al there'll be some noise
because of you know sampling uh but if
you look at a histogram of all the sites
across the genome that are heter zous
for particular isolate you should expect
like a normal distribution standard
around 0.5 and that's what we saw for
some of the isets for other isets we saw
you know bodal distributions with Peaks
at 0.33 and
0.66 these are likely genome white
triploids we also saw evidence of
tetrols or possible higher uh copy
number uh
isolates we we we don't have a a
chromosome level reference genome for
phyo capsy but there had been a genetic
map published before we were able to
Anchor our snip markers to that genetic
map to assign them to linkage groups
which you can think of you know
essentially as chromosomes and it was
really interesting to see that even
within a genome we saw all this copy
number variation so for this particular
isolate here I'm showing uh you know 16
of it
uh chromosomes appear to be deployed and
then it has two chromosomes that it
seems to have three copies of and you
know this was really widespread um
didn't really seem to be much uh
patterns all of the linkage groups were
of we found to be triploid or of a
higher Ploy level than at least one
isolate uh we did find a couple of
linkage groups that that had the highest
incidence of higher PL levels but one
thing that I think was interesting about
this was that it appears that this anlo
was mitotically derived as opposed to
meiotically derived and the reason that
I think that is because within a certain
clonal group we would find individual
isolates that would be anoyed for a
chromosome and that wouldn't be shared
by other isolates within that same
phonal lineage uh so it seems like this
you know like widespread variation
arises very spontaneously and very
rapidly in populations of
C
so we assay all of our isolates for B
type by co-culturing them with isolat of
no mating type checking for the presence
of oospores
um we use that as a Fen type in a genome
wide Association study so if you look at
the Manhattan plot here on the x-axis is
basically chromosomal location typically
there'll be alternating colors for
chromosomes but again like we don't have
chromosome level assemblies so they
scaffolds of the genome assembly and
then the y- AIS the negative log 10 P
value so the higher the point the higher
the association with that that fan type
uh we saw a strong Peak on scaffold 4
this trait had been mapped by others in
experimental crosses they found the same
result a region on scaffold 4 that
determines M type uh we also
corroborated previous results that show
that the A1 isolates uh had one hype at
that Locus and the A2 isolates had two
Hypes so it seemed that uh mating type
in phyo capsy and this has been shown in
in other old my species appears to be
inherited analogous lead to like XY sex
determination species uh such as in
animals so we also uh assayed the
isolates for resistance to the fungicide
uh methoxy which uh was used I think for
the first time in the 70s I believe and
know resistance showed up shortly after
that ined
species and this trait hadn't been
mapped before in phy capsy we found a
strong Peak on scaffold 62 it had been
assumed for a long time that the target
site of methoxy was RNA polymerase 3 uh
because methoxy interferes with our
Rosal RNA synthesis uh in all my seats
we didn't find any genes annotated as
subunits of RNA p 3 in that in that
region but what we did find was this gen
Gene
rrp5 which is a gene involved in
assembling pre-ribosomal RNA into
ribosomes so it seemed to us like a
pretty strong candidate for the Target
side of methoxy and since we published
this actually uh a Crossing experiment
in phyo festin has implicated the same
gene in uh metal axle
resistance so the the the gws results
for mating type and nephin oxin
resistance were very promising uh we
were very excited to you know use the
same approach for veillance on on
different different pepper varieties so
we started to generate that fanpic data
uh we took a subset of 117 isolet that
were genetically unique from our isolate
collection and we challenged those onto
16 different varieties of peppers these
were both commercial hybrids and lines
that have been used by others as
differentials for phyto
caps we evaluated plants for incidents
of mortality over time time turn that
into audc altogether this was about 1900
unique combinations of host and pathogen
so it was quite a bit of phenotyping and
we repeated this twice for most
combinations so you know I guess the
first question is like were there
interactions between pathogen isolate
and pepper variety or accession and that
Thea table says yes but it doesn't
really tell us much about the nature of
those interactions we wanted to kind of
characterize the pattern of those
interactions so you know we tried to
visualize this in a couple different
ways if if you look at this plot uh each
subplot represents a different
isolate on the x-axis are the different
pepper varieties increasing an order of
susceptibility from left to right in
each plot the the black dash line is the
average level of disease caused you know
across all isolates on a particular
pepper EX session and then the red line
is the level of disease caused by that
particular isolate um so kind you know
kind of a lot to like take in but a
couple of things that uh we noticed
looking at this data uh one is that on
average the disease caused by particular
isolate tends to increase with the
overall susceptibility of a pepper
excession although there were some cases
where that wasn't the case right like
like here another thing we saw was that
there was a lot of
uh variation between isolates that came
from the same location so the background
color of these plots indicates what site
they came from in New York um so like
all these blue isolates came from one
field for example if you look at this
dark these dark green squares these were
two different isolates that came from a
squash field in Long Island you'll see
that one caused you know fairly average
levels of disease on all on all the
pepper varieties and this other isol
same location caus very high high levels
of disease uh across the
board you know we wanted to kind of uh
find ways to characterize this variation
more and because I'm trained as a plant
breeder I I I turn to to methods used in
plant breeding uh so one thing that I
looked at is what we called veilance
stability uh so this is analogous to
like yield stability analysis that's
used by plant breeders in analysis of
genotype by environment interaction data
so that the idea is you you evaluate
different varieties of a of a crop in
different environments and then you can
look at how stable the performance of
those varieties is across the
environments uh by regressing the
individual variety yield on the average
yield for each environment uh the the a
good uh example of this um would be like
a variety that's very responsive to
fertility uh
that variety would have a very high
slope in this analysis it would perform
very poorly in low fernal environments
and it would perform very well in highly
fernal environments whereas a variety
that's more stable would just have kind
of a more uh intermediate uh performance
across the board so the way that we
looked at this we basically treated
isolates as crop varieties um and pepper
hols as environments and uh regress
disease caused by individual ises on the
average disease seen on the
pepper um when you do that you kind of
see that isolates fall into one of three
categories low slope and low intercept
those are isolates that cause low levels
of disease across the board low
intercept and high slope those are
isolates that tend to cause average
levels of disease on all of the pepper
accessions and then isolates with high
intercept and low slope those are
isolates that cause high levels of
disease on all Peppers uh you know that
tells us something and then another
parameter that you can get from this
model is the mean square error it's like
how well can you predict the disease
caused by an isolate as a linear uh uh
relationship with the overall
susceptibility of the host and in most
cases you can predicted very well most
isolates had a low mpare error but there
were a few that that had a really high
mpare error in other words you you
couldn't really tell how it was going to
what kind of disease would cause in a
pepper accession uh knowing solely that
overall susceptibility level of that
pepper okay we we next tried to look at
the association between pathogen
subpopulation and these variance
phenotypes um so here I'm showing the
principal components analysis of the GE
typic data the molecular marker data and
we use K clusters to assign isolates to
one of five clusters and then we
regressed veillance on each IND
individual pepper variety uh as as a
function of their you know assignment to
those clusters and in most cases what we
found was that the genetic cell
population of isolate didn't really
influence how much disease it can cause
on most of these pepper varieties with
the exception of red and white the most
susceptible pepper on average in our
experiment we started looking at
multivariant F types and we saw we saw a
very different uh uh conclusion
excuse
me so this is the principal components
analysis of the phenotypic data so the
Matrix of disease outcome uh for all the
isolates and all of those different
pepper
accessies uh principal components one
and two explain most of the variation in
our data set uh principal component one
was very highly correlated with just
overall average Varin across all the
pepper ex sessions that wasn't associ
population principal component two uh
was very highly correlated with the
slope from that stability analysis so
like the uh increase in virence as a
function of pepper
susceptibility also wasn't associated
with subpopulation the principal
component three had a very strong
association with P sub population and
you can see here that along this
x-axis denoting principal component
three uh you know all the isolates
belonging to genetic cluster the green
cluster are fall on the left side of
that axis and all the isolates on the
belonging to the the blue cluster fall
on the right side of that
axis this principal component is more
difficult to interpret uh but if you
look at the loadings of the individual
uh pepper variety variance data on that
principal component uh the way I
interpret it I'm not sure if this is
like correct but it's basically uh
measuring how much disease the isolates
cause on the intermediately resistant
pepper accessions uh controlled by their
um the disease causing the most
susceptible pepper excesss so if you
look at the individual plots belonging
to the isolates with the most extreme
values on that principal component so
this would be that Green Dot over here
and this isolate would be that blue dot
over here you can see that that this
isolate causes lower than average
disease and the most most resistant and
most susceptible he
but much higher than average disease on
the intermediately resistant pepper
varieties whereas this isolate causes
higher than average disease on the most
susceptible and the most resistant
pepper variety but much lower than
average disease on the intermediately
resistant pepper varieties uh I I think
what this means is that there are uh
host specific virulence variants that
affect uh the disease observed on these
intermediately resistant pepper
varieties but you can't really piece
that out unless you control for much
larger effect variants affecting their
ability to cause disease on the most
susceptible pepper
EXs so you know like we do mag type and
fungicide sensitivity we did a genome
white Association study we found four
Loi that were significantly associated
with virulence in all cases these four
Loi were associated with broad spectrum
virulence so the the virent O at these
lowside resulted in higher disease on
all of the pepper exceptions that we
tested uh we weren't able to map any
variants that affected disease on only
individual pepper
EXs and when when we look at the genes
in the regions of these hits uh we found
annotations that kind of support a
virulence function so these are kind of
close-ups of no manh plot Peaks and the
track underneath shows um Gene
anotations and Alterna colors uh the red
genes are rxlr rxlr affector genes you
can see that in case of the peak on
scaffold 39 the peak s was actually
inside one of these effectors seems like
pretty strong support that this you know
there's actual um AAL function for this
hit uh similar to SCA 37 although they
wer in the
gene um the purple sequences are
polycon uh Gene annotations so genes
involved in cell wall degradation and in
in the case of the in scaffold 93 we saw
that there was a cluster of genes
annotated having a
polyglas uh
role okay so what what's the make of
these results like it you know we
generate a lot of data and like kind of
scratched our heads and try to tell some
story about it make sense of it uh what
are the actual practical
implications I I think for one thing we
showed that you know GW works pretty
well for candidate Gene identification
and sexually reproducing
pathogens um we showed that both for the
M type for the fungicide sensitivity and
in the case of these larger effect VAR
slow side that affected all of the
pepper accessions in our
experiment you know other breeders and
Pathologists use the terminology
physiological races to refer to phyto
capsy populations based on the set of
isolates and the set of pepper
accessions we included in our experiment
I'm not sure I would use that
terminology to me that implies like
large effect qualitative Gene for Gene
interactions that influence the presence
or absence of disease we saw evidence
for much smaller
quantitative uh Gene for Gene
interactions that influence relative
disease levels on different varieties uh
I'm not sure what the best way is to
classify you know isolates or strains
based on the data that we observed I
don't think there is an easy way to do
it but physiological rases I think maybe
some
oversimplification that being said you
know maybe with a different set of is
different set of Po gen we would have
had different
conclusions so you know like I said we
were able to identify virence variants
with uh medium to large effect across
all of the uh pepper hostar experiment
but we couldn't really we knew that
there was there were variants that had
an effect on individual pepper varieties
but we couldn't pick those out uh
probably were just underpowered because
of small know relatively small sample
sizes
in terms of implications for pepper
breeding you know if I was a pepper
breeder what would I do knowing this
information I think I would just treat
the resistance to different strains like
a correlated trait you know in terms of
screening early generation lines I'd
probably evaluate them against one
isolate uh one strain of the pathogen
and then as I move forward and and
evaluate more advanced lines I would
test them against an increased number of
isolates so how how am I going to take
this like background and move forward as
a eggplant and tomato Breer I'll try to
do this in like two minutes um I think
it really just depends on a Case by case
basis uh so as an example tomato leaf
mold is a disease that's really
important in our region in high tunnels
and it's also a disease that has been
very well characterized by molecular
plant Pathologists many R genes and a
virulence Losi in in the fungus have
been cloned here there's very strong
evidence of you know very clear
qualitative Gene for Gene interactions
uh I I worked a little bit on this as a
grad student in a project led by my
labmate Martha sudman uh we characterize
isolates from around the state uh race
type then we determined that everything
that we found were races zero and two
tomato breeders tend to use one
resistance Gene cf9 in resistance
breeding programs that works against
those races so for the time being I
think uh resistance variety should hold
up uh but I think it's also prudent to
maybe pyramid additional uh resistance
genes as well
anticipating uh breakdown my predecessor
in my position Martha mler did a lot of
excellent work on early blight and
suboral leaf spot identified new sources
of resistance to these diseases um
there's really nothing known about the
population structure of the of the fungi
that cause these diseases do they
reproduce sexually how much variation is
there between strains in the same field
between Fields uh does the resistance
hold them equally to different strains
uh there you know there's really a lot
of unknowns and I think a lot of
information that would be valuable there
uh my lab is also working on vertican
Resistance um if you you know when when
I ask eggplant uh Growers and extension
agents what the biggest problem in
eggplant is if I ask 10 people they all
tend to tell me the same thing which is
vertican which is good to hear as a
breeder so I can kind of focus um
there's no resistance available to
vertican in eggplant in tomato vertican
has been controlled for I don't know 50
or 80 years with a single Gene uh ve
that's been overcome in other parts of
the country uh we don't know if there's
uh you know ve um uh strains that
overcome ve in New York I think that's a
a valuable question to answer we also
don't know how much doesn't matter for
eggplant uh is there association between
Varin of eggplant variance of tomato I
think there's important questions to
answer
there so to conclude you know uh as a
vegetable breeder moving forward I don't
think for every single disease I work on
I'm going to uh test you know my
breeding lines against 100 strains of of
the pathogen but I I think there are are
some uh important lessons right like the
scale and scope pathogen monitoring
characterization depends on the
particular case in the case of tomato
leaf mold it might be monitoring for for
individual Avance genes that are already
cloned that we know will allow them to
overtake that deployed Argin in the case
of septor and early BL I think there's
much more fundamental information that
need to be uncovered first uh I don't
expect to do like any of this by myself
I really look forward to collaborating
with Pathologists and another thing I'm
really interested in is you know
coordinating networks to test germ plasm
in geographically diverse locations
right because one thing we can do is do
artificial inoculations in the
greenhouse with different strains of the
pathogen but we can also just test germ
Plasma in different locations and rely
natural inoculum and look at how durable
resistance is um with that approach
so with that I'd like to thank all the
people who contributed to my PhD
research that I talked about today as
well as uh the members of my lab
currently barene D young Cameron Downey
Howard rice and uh Lana Castillo so with
that I'll be happy to answer any
questions if if there's any time
left question in the room here and then
we'll go to uh yeah um back to by the RO
how much section will reproduction
occurs in the
field um pretty much in in so the
question for Zoom was uh how much sexual
reproduction occurs in the field with
phyo
capsy uh almost in every case when we
sample strains from the field we
identify both mating types and the GE
typic data also supports you know very
frequent sexual reproduction so uh it
tends to be uh the case that both M
types are present it and sexual
reproduction is necessary for over
wintering which which we see as
well
yes first off I want to say that graph
subx
results question isoss pepp Tes you have
a sense of how much I
uh so so thank you Adam the the question
was um in the different pepper lines
that we tested how much heter zygosity
is present in those lines that's a good
question so we used a mixture of
commercial hybrids and open pollinated
pepper
varieties um the commercial hybrids
should be you know pretty homogeneous um
and we saw pretty consistent results in
some of the open pollinated varieties
that we included we did see more
variable results and there could be some
heterogenity within those
yeah no there there are a couple
questions question from Ricky do you
think sparse testing methods would help
alleviate the experimental constraints
challenging all Gene types by all
isolates or do you think the level of
pathogen variation you observed will
feel hinder this that that's a that's a
really interesting question um and I
guess the answer is is yes
um
uh that's not the way that we set up the
experiment um but I think it is possible
to like Leverage relationships between
the isolates to not necessarily F typ
all combinations but generate useful
information um and then there's another
question uh and that is that when we've
see the history of plant breeding
breeders have been pretty successful in
breeding for disease resistance even
though they have little knowledge of the
type of isense they're working with from
this can we conclude that they have been
mostly selecting for broad spectrum
resistance and how does this interaction
carry over in time that's that's a great
question too um and I I think I would
say that that there are many cases of
breeders deploying a resistance
Gene and that resistance Gene lasting
for decades but there are also many
cases of breeders deploying a gene and
it lasting a year or two right I think
both of those things have have been
observed
um well the last question is from uh
Marina can you elaborate a little on
possible Pros or cons of using scaffold
level sequences for Goos rather than
chromosomal level uh if you know if if
we had chromosome
level uh assembly that would be
preferable it's it's it's visually it's
nicer and then we can also identify uh
you know whether different hits are are
linked on the same
chromosome uh it's very hard with with
many very small scaffolds that that
could actually be physically or
genetically very closely
linked um and I guess that's it for the
questions oh build might Happ um is
there no sexual reproduction in the
B is there
that yeah that's is there sexual
reproduction in the Geneva phyo farm so
uh yes uh you know Chris in the past has
intentionally inoculated that field with
with multiple mating types with the
intention of really studying you know
how Le frequencies change over time and
a sexually repr reproducing population
but for field trials we we intend to
inoculate only with one mating type
hoping not to contribute to uh you know
long lasting populations so in those
trials there's no resal population that
that is the Hope but you
know for all of our best efforts to
contain pathogens they they find a way
to spread around um yeah I have one more
question yes in that massive study
looking at the range of isos over the
several posts how stable are those
or that that's that's an excellent
question and I apologize for not
repeating the earlier questions the
question was how stable were the
phenotypes uh uh the aggressiveness
levels of the isolates that that's
that's a really good question and one
that I didn't talk about
um what we what we found generally was
that the lowly and the kind of
intermediately aggressive isolates were
stable uh across you know different uh
replicates but the isolates that tended
to cause very high levels of disease on
all of the pepper sessions those were
the least stable
um you know we would inoculate with a
strain and we would see you know very
severe uh you know plant uh death we've
be able to repeat that maybe a few times
um and then it would just would lose its
its veilance uh it's you know it's I
think there's a lot
of spontaneous variation like that in
phyo species and we heard a little bit
about that last week in terms of
fungicide sensitivity uh as well from
from syvia I think there's lot of
interesting questions there yeah so we
want to thank you again Greg for an
excellent presentation
and just look forward to working with
you
than this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu